right now everything's you know on
Twitter or on Facebook hey you look at
my link and that's great that's that's
how things spread these days and spread
very quickly but you think the sort of
the old way of just going and seeing
someone face-to-face is the power of
that is I think it adds in certain areas
that's true there are certain people at
a certain level of success that you do
have to engage one-on-one I think
there's nothing wrong with getting your
word out there to massive audiences on
Twitter and Facebook and all of that I
think all of that stuff is important for
a filmmaker but you can't ever replace
that sitting down with somebody and
looking them in the eye and saying I
need this or my film will not be
completed and you know touching them on
a heart level so that they write that
check out and I think maybe if you're
new in this business and you're young
and you don't have those social skills
that's something you're gonna need to
work on because you need to be a
well-rounded fundraiser I hate to say
that you need to be a well-rounded
filmmaker and part of it is having human
interaction well especially to for
people that are used to dealing with
computers and some say that younger
generations lack that social skill you
know whether it's true or not how would
someone learn that that's a great it's
almost like people that are in
development and you know fundraising all
that where do you go to learn those
skills sort of the courting that goes on
with getting to know it's really helpful
to have a mentor if you find somebody in
the business who has been there done
that who's gone down those roads they
can help you and and it's really
important to get that help I know that
even myself with all the experience that
I've had in the business my executive
producer Mike Green who gave me the
first money is
who has operated on such high levels in
the business and in the industry that
the skills that he showed me while I was
making this film were invaluable to me
and then just the other day a young
filmmaker who volunteered to do some
work for us while we were in New York
screening at Lincoln Center uh she was
telling me about a problem that she was
having on a film that she was doing and
she asked me if I thought it would be a
good idea for her to confront the person
at a major studio face-to-face who was
giving her trouble and I was able to say
to her you know what you're going to do
is going to alienate you and that person
and is not going to further your work in
any way it may bring you momentary
satisfaction but is that what you're
looking for maybe you need to rethink
this whole thing and so I was able to
share something with her that I have
learned and I think that's what we all
have to do for each other all filmmakers
have to mentor other people so your
advice to her was to maybe handle it in
a different way maybe more graciously
not only more graciously but to look at
what she was in pursuit of and to look
what her other options were and to see
why it is that she wanted to confront
this person and what she was going to
get out of it to just really think about
her position because it's a very small
business and going out there and
alienating people in positions that you
are going to come across again as you
climb the ladder is never a good idea
you know we all make mistakes along the
way and we all pay for them
you